you probably remember that last year Fox
News CEO Roger Ailes was forced to
resign after a long list of women came
out and accused him of sexual harassment
and then last week Fox News host Bill
O'Reilly was fired because of similar
allegations there are now allegations
about Sean Hannity and the accuser is
actually an interesting part of the
story because it's a known entity
popular Fox News host Sean Hannity is
now being accused of sexual harassment
by attorney and blogger Debbie Schlussel
and she used to be a guest on Fox News
she said Friday that Sean Hannity once
invited her to come to his hotel room
she said no and then was reportedly
never again asked back to appear on fox
news here's Debbie Schlussel on the Pat
Campbell podcast last week and he asked
me to come to meet him at this book
signing so I met him there and it was
very awkward he had me stand up there
with him while he signed books and I
felt very weird these people don't know
me and they dinkum for me to sign their
book right and so then I left to get
ready for the for the show and he said
why don't you come with me back to my
hotel and I said no I have to get ready
for the show and then he tried to get me
to go back to with him to the hotel
after the show after see and bill shine
is executive producer treated me
horribly and then every time I tried to
open my mouth and say something they
yelled at me and said obey your host you
can't say anything or we're going to
shut up your microphone and if I when I
looked at the tape I barely said
anything and then after that I was a
booked on a show again and he called to
me and yelled at me and I and it was
being clear to me that I didn't go back
to his hotel with him after and I kind
of knew I would it be back on his show
and his um longtime executive producer
she quit being his executive producer
because there's a big story behind it he
wanted something from her she wouldn't
give it yeah
so this has now sort of been walked back
Debbie Schlussel has responded so Sean
Hannity initially said this is
absolutely bogus this is completely and
totally bogus
Russell responded by saying I never
thought I was sexually harassed by Sean
Hannity I thought he was weird and
creepy not someone I liked sexual
harassment has a special meaning under
the law and I would never accuse him of
that so it's becoming sort of a semantic
thing at the same time Russell said to a
legal blog quote everything I said was
true and truth is an absolute bar to
defamation he on the other hand as a
murky record on truth that's to law news
so that this is so there's so many
aspects as one is you've got the
anti-feminist men's rights activist
saying see this is why we can't believe
women about rape claims but this is
really something else Debbie Schlussel
is standing by what she said Sean
Hannity did what she is not saying
apparently now is that this is sexual
harassment in the eyes of the law just
that she found it creepy if more women
come out and accuse Sean Hannity of
sexual harassment to the point where it
seems to be a pattern I think that this
will blow up I think as it currently
stands this is probably going to end up
being much ado about nothing with regard
to Sean Hannity's role at Fox News
broadly it doesn't seem as though Fox
News is exactly a safe haven for women
or a place where women can be completely
comfortable knowing that this type of
behavior wouldn't be allowed but as far
as the specifics of this she's told her
she's made the assertions about what
took place and she is now saying that
she stands by everything that she said
took place but that she did not call it
sexual harassment in the eyes of the law
so will this take Sean Hannity down no I
don't believe this will take Sean
Hannity down
if this explodes into something else of
the Bill O'Reilly or Bill Cosby sort of
category then I think we'll revisit it
and see
what what new evidence is presented but
I think this is probably going to go
away today's episode of the David Pakman
show is made possible in part by Warby
Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker recently
did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine cost that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS